at this altitude I can discover this
episode is brought to you by Express VPN
I've been using expressvpn since last
summer and I started using it as a full
retail paying customer I always test
things before considering sponsors and I
find it to be a super reliable way to
make sure that my data are secure and
encrypted you're like how I said data
are like a pompous ass but I like to
ensure that my data are secure and
encrypted but to do so without slowing
down my internet speed if you ever use
public Wi-Fi let's say hotel or coffee
shop where I often work and as many of
my listeners do you're often sending
data over an open network meaning no
encryption whatsoever one way to ensure
that all of your data are encrypted and
cannot be easily read by hackers or
script kiddies or whoever is by using
Express VPN and the onboarding process
for expressvpn meaning the signup flow
the use of the product is one of the
best I've ever seen in my life all you
need to do is download the expressvpn
app on your computer or smartphone and
then use the internet just as you
normally would you click one button in
the expressvpn app to secure 100% of
your network data it's kind of
ridiculously simple and as many of you
know I only recommend brands that I have
researched and vetted thoroughly for me
of the many VPN solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market and I use it personally here a
few reasons why first privacy expressvpn
does not log your data lots of cheap or
free VPNs make money by selling your
data believe it or not to ad companies
and so on expressvpn developed a
technology called trusted server to
prevent their servers from logging your
information second speed many VPNs slow
your connection down
or make your device seems sluggish just
to a crawl I've been using expressvpn
for a while now as I mentioned and my
internet speeds are blazingly fast I
don't even notice it honestly I forget
that it's even on so that includes when
I connect to servers thousands of miles
away or during travel I can still stream
HD quality videos with zero lag the last
thing there really sets expressvpn apart
is how easy it is to use as I mentioned
earlier unlike other VPNs you don't have
to input or program anything you just
start up the app click one button and
that's it super super simple and by the
way it's not just me saying all this
about but expressvpn you've got
TechRadar the verge CNET and many other
publications rating Express VPM as the
number one VPN in zippered so consider
protecting yourself with the VPN that I
use and trust use my link expressvpn
dot-com / Tim today and get an extra
three months free on a one-year package
that's expressvpn
dot-com / Tim visit expressvpn com / Tim
to learn more
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand-new cereal
that I eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero sugar I
just ate a huge ball of their cocoa
flavor about an hour ago after a short
workout magic spoon cereal has received
a lot of attention since launching last
year Time magazine included in their
list of best inventions of 2019 and
Forbes called it the future of cereal it
tastes just like your favorite sugary
cereal from childhood remember that but
it's actually good for you
each serving has 11 grams of protein 3
grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar and
only 110 calories it's also gluten free
grain free keto friendly soy free and
GMO free all the things it's delicious
and I don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy version of X stuff
is not delicious but these guys really
nail it magic spoon has nailed it it
comes in your favorite traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack at magic spoon
comm slash Tim or you can just grab a
box or a bunch of boxes I'm going to
order some more today of the cocoa which
is my personal favorite but there is a
new contender for favorite flavour
because they just launched two limited
edition flavors honey nut and peanut
butter which are delicious I am a sucker
for peanut butter and it is outstanding
so I think cocoa and peanut butter are
my two new favorite flavors and fun fact
my friends are also obsessed with magic
spoon one of the podcasts most popular
guest dr. peter tia routinely crushes 6
to 7 servings at a time that's a lot
with no glycemic response he's looked at
this with a glucometer he likes it so
much he invested other friends two very
fine gentlemen and also past podcast
guests Kevin Rose and Ryan holiday also
invested so check it out see what the
buzz is about good a magic spoon dot-com
/ Tim and grab a variety pack or cocoa
which is my favorite or anything else
but see what strikes your fancy why not
try a variety pack and be sure to use
code Tim at checkout my listeners that's
you get free shipping and a 100%
happiness guarantee so if you're not a
fan if you don't love it they'll give
you a full refund no questions asked
again check it out magic spoon dot-com
Ford / Tim that's magic spoon comm /y
Tim take a look hello boys and girls
ladies and germs this is Tim Ferriss and
welcome to another episode of the Tim
Ferriss show this isn't just any other
episode it is a very special and
exciting one for me but let's back up
this show is about deconstructing
world-class performers to tease out the
habits routines favorite books and so on
that you can apply to your own life and
this particular episode
I think delivers the goods and then some
my guest is Hugh Jackman I've wanted to
have Hugh on the show for a very very
long time
who is Hugh Jackman if you have to ask
that I don't know where you've been
living under a rock
I'll keep this intro short Hugh Jackman
is an Academy Award nominated Golden
Globe and Tony award-winning performer
who has made an impression on audiences
around the world certainly audiences of
all ages with his multi-hyphenate career
persona he's done everything he is as
successful on stage in front of live
crowds as he is on film he's a beast in
the gym this man does it all you can
find him on instagram at the Hugh
Jackman Twitter at real Hugh Jackman on
Facebook Hugh Jackman and there is one
resource I'll mention here he talks
about converting photographs into
puzzles and the website for that is
portrait puzzles calm it'll all make
sense he'll tie it all together and
without further ado please enjoy a
wide-ranging thoroughly enjoyable
conversation with none other than Hugh
Jackman one quick note on timing for
context this episode was recorded on May
21st 2020 before the death of George
Floyd
Hugh welcome to the show Jim great to be
a man I'm very excited I am so thrilled
that we are able to connect on the
podcast I've wanted to do this for so
long
yeah and I have so many different
questions I've wanted to explore with
you and I thought we would start this
might be a strange place to start but
I'll start there nonetheless and that is
in the course of doing homework for this
conversation
I found an anecdote that you in the
mornings sometimes read a book with your
wife or read to each other is that
something you still do and how did that
start every day I nicked the idea from
Patrick Stewart I was on set with
Patrick Stewart who those who don't know
him is great actor who played professor
X and the x-men series Star Trek lots of
stuff and he said to me that when he was
about 60 he realized that he was never
gonna read all the books that he wanted
to read in his life he did the
calculation and so he decided that no
matter what time he his call was let's
say he's picked up at 5:00 he whatever
time he would have woken up he wakes up
30 minutes earlier gets a cup of tea and
goes back to bed and he got any reads
and he said I don't read the paper
because it makes me angry
I don't read my emails coz it usually
makes me anxious gets my mind going he
said what's the other thing he doesn't
read doesn't do emails Oh scripts he won
work he said that makes him anxious he
said I read a book the kind of book did
you pick up when you go on vacation
the I've got nothing to do a book and
he's been doing that for years and he
said the reason I do it first thing in
the morning is the day just gets away
from you and you think oh I'll read
later in the evening but you don't he
says in weekends he spends an hour so
for Christmas this year I gave them a
couple of books which I got off your
podcast from your from Seth Cody Esther
Perel Seth Godin one about their five
books in Berea which absolutely yeah we
never resolved that and we met Esther
and I signed up the Seth Cohen's
marketing kind of workshop thing that
unfortunate got canceled
so we wake up whatever time we gotta get
up so I go down I make a cup of coffee
for me cup of tea for Deb we come back
up I have a cold shower first another
thing I learned from you yeah from your
for our body book I was getting ready
for Wolverine the old Cole bar so I have
a cold shower every morning and then we
go back and we read and we read for at
least 30 minutes and then we meditate
together and that way when it's become
our like favorite time of the day as a
couple we and we know that no matter
what happens in the day which invariably
gets away from you you've had that
quality time together and so that's
that's just been a godsend assume in an
absolute lesson I love that because if
I'm looking at for instance my own
experience with my girlfriend who I'm
very close to who and we live together
it's so easy to say we're going to find
the quality time at dinner after dinner
at this point in the afternoon and then
the day gets away with you so you're
your front loading it in a way so that
it doesn't get lost and do you do you
read the same book at the same time do
you read out loud to each other we read
out loud to each other so we we split it
up we do half half when we read out loud
to each other and it's interesting what
if you've got something on your mind
you know often it stirs during the night
and and it could be I'm not just talking
negative stuff could be ideas I find the
evening when your subconscious is
probably brewing at it's at its highest
level lots of ideas or anxieties come to
the surface so I find the first thing in
the morning you know will be five
minutes into reading right now we're
reading David Brooks the second mountain
book and we might just stop and say hey
I'm worried about this could be
something that the kids or staff or
stuff's on my mind and and then we'll
just end up talking about that
you know um but often just the reading
itself sparks things in us gives us
ideas things to talk about
come together with but we we read the
same book out aloud to each other and
I'm gonna come back to the meditation
because you mentioned it but since we're
on the topic of books what what books
if any come to mind I know you read a
lot have you gifted the most to other
people hmm I learned this from a great
mate of mine Billy Shaw who's often
known as Saint Billy runs no Kid Hungry
Share Our Strength you know that
organization I do
yeah they're incredible and so he came
over to my place one day and he gave me
two books that I now gift very regularly
one is EB White's here is New York and
the other one is David Foster Wallace's
speech this is water his commencement
speech I've heard you talk about the
David Foster Wallace once I know you
know that and he said I said I haven't
read either of these and he said man I
would I learn dal Ong time ago it's
really nice to get books but it can be a
burden to give a big book because people
feel like on a theme in a month
oh I having dinner with them next week
and share my book but like the David
Foster Wallace is a 15 minute book and
the ABY book here is New York the New
York had a program post-world War two
with our invite the greatest writers in
the world to come to New York and just
pay them for three months just to write
essays about New York so that was his
and it's amazing to read a 1949 account
of New York and how much of the spirit
still resonates now so that's the little
book that to anyone who lives in New
York or likes New York I give and in
terms of fiction and this completely
breaks a rule to him because this is a
long book but I was gifted actually by
Gary Hart
senator Gary ha do I collide in a movie
the overstory by Richard powers I'm not
sure if you read that but that's the
most transformative bit of fiction I
have read in a long time I need to read
it it's been recommended so many times
it's sitting on my Kindle and I started
reading it I remember I cried for about
a half hour and it said whatever it said
point zero zero one percent complete oh
my god how big is this book if we can
speak with it for those who don't know
the book could you could you give it a
just a quick description yeah it's
Richard Belzer I believe in won the
Pulitzer I think it did
it it's a piece of fiction interweaving
about eight story lines of humans but
what you realize that the the
misdirection of the book is by the end
you realize the book is completely about
treats so we might relegate trees or
nature to some five or ten percent of
our awareness and this book what it does
is draws you in in these incredible
human stories and these very varied
characters and their varying degrees of
interaction with nature in various
different forms but by the end you
realize the book actually the main
character in the book is trees is nature
and it completely reverses the way you
look at the world when you walk outside
now I promise you after you read that
book Tim you will sit in your backyard
and you'll notice things you have never
noticed before oh I've been alright
my lay my complacency has been called I
will I just think with it it works on
you in the way nature does see it's
patient and it's in no rush into it's
it's slow and it's steady and it's true
well I think that the word true maybe is
a segue to meditation I know you've
meditated for decades now and you and
Deb meditate in the mornings and I say
that as a segue because at least from me
meditation has been a tool of that
provides helps to provide clarity in in
some respects could you describe your
meditation practice and what you feel
are the main benefits that are derived
from that practice sure I was introduced
to meditation when I was at drama school
and I it was a form of Transcendental
Meditation there's lots of different
types of of meditation just very briefly
it involves the use of a mantra which
you are given which you repeatedly sound
and the very basic concept is that we
the nature of our minds
to always be working I'll always be
thinking and the trick to life is not
letting that might be your master but to
let it be a servant then it's an
incredible thing once and become once
it's running the show and you know it's
very easy to get off track so during
this period of meditation you are given
a mantra which was described to me as
the mind is often called the monkey mind
and these some philosophies so monkey
you know is very energetic and if not
given something to do will be
mischievous so the mantra is like
basically saying to the monkey mind I
need you to climb to the top of that
telegraph pole and when you get to the
top I need you to climb back down and
when you get to the bottom I need you to
climb back up and when you get to the
top I need you climb back down so it's
just giving this activity so the mantra
or this word that is silently repeated
ends up fading away and the best way I
can describe it is the effect that it
has on me I mean sometimes I fall asleep
by the way which is totally fine and
clearly what my body needed but when you
first pour a glass of water it's cloudy
and then in a period of time that all
settles and you see crystal clear
through the glass through the water
that's what meditation does for me it's
got that feeling where things drop down
I have a feeling of coming home the
feeling of experiencing my true self and
not just being caught up in the monkey
mind or being reactive to life and it
gives me a finer energy I don't always
get out of meditation like ready to you
know do a one-hour peloton class but I
always come out with a finer energy it
feels my intention feels clearer my
listening is more purposeful and and
things feel easier and more connected do
you meditate then twice a day in these
these the what I guess one might
consider the traditional TM format do
you didn't if you meditate in the
afternoons or later in the day how do
you time that for yourself
so I I always did it twice a day for
years so I started yeah when I was 23
I'm 51 now so I did it very regularly
twice a day and I'm bound three or four
years ago I kind of let go of the duty
element there was and I can be guilty of
this a this is good for you should be
doing this don't fall off that wagon you
know it's a slippery slope so I and once
I let go of that - I just had a kind of
experiment with myself I was like okay
B'Elanna you meditate when you really
want to meditate and that has turned
into a practice where it's every morning
for sure and then definitely when I'm
working if I'm on a movie set or I'm
working in theater there will always be
a second one but sometimes I'll let the
afternoon one go
and when I say afternoon I can't sit
down area I get restless leg syndrome so
after about four or five o'clock it's
uncomfortable who made us sit for 20
minutes so I will do it around lunchtime
we'll just talk to lunch I'd love to to
use this as a path to talking about
self-care and maybe to sex up the
expression a little bit the the building
and recharging of your energetic
reservoir and here's why I'm using such
fancy wording but I think it's
appropriate we have we have we have a
few mutual friends and one saw you
perform on stage in I believe it was New
York and what he said to me this is
someone Peter who can work easily 1214
hours a day if he wants to for seven
days a week non-stop for years at a time
and he said that he could not conceive
of
doing what you do even twice a week and
let alone the maximum number of times
you might do it in a given week I don't
know what that number is you could speak
to it but could you describe your
emotional energy practices and
replenishing approach when it comes to
let's just say stage stage performances
and stage work because it's it's really
hard for me to even wrap my head around
how you have that much energy output hmm
repeatedly in a given week you see I
find this hard to believe man because I
sit here and and I hear you and Peter
talking about the hundred mile swim you
know some of the crazy stuff that sounds
to me like wow I didn't even know the
human body could do that little in the
amount of training it goes for that kind
of pushing through that energy that
pushes through pain or if you see that
documentary Kim swims when I watch her I
just go wow that that's amazing to me
because I know in my heart that I was
born to be on the stage it's taken me a
long time to feel the same feeling on a
soundstage for acting good one of my
favorite movies of all time and
definitely my favorite quote from a
movie of all time is from Chariots of
Fire which I loved as a kid and Eric
Lidell who's the religious runner who
decides not to run on the Sabbath during
the Olympics you've seen the movie right
yeah no so this is great scene he's
meant to be going off after the Olympics
to do missionary work and China handing
our Bibles or something and his sisters
talking to him she's like you got to
throw away this silly running thing we
have really important work God's working
to do um why are you doing this and
spending time on this you know basically
kind of accusing him of not following
God's will and he just says he looks at
her and he says but I feel his pleasure
when I run and I've always somehow that
line it always makes me tear up just
saying it
that's what I feel on stage there's a
kind of natural energy and what I keep
saying my kids actually don't settle
find that thing that resonates with you
in that way or you feel some kind of the
pleasure of the universe of
consciousness like there's some joy
where you feel you can do it longer and
in that way it's not such a Herculean
effort although I'm gonna tell you in a
second I have a bunch of sort of rituals
and things that I do to make sure that I
can be my best but there is a natural
energy that I understand okay I don't
know how you do that but maybe that's
the same way I don't know how you train
for ultramarathons for example so in
terms of self-care on Broadway I have a
bunch of rules or when I was doing my
tour
don't drink alcohol before and I really
limited after it's really important for
me to wake up feeling in a good frame of
mind rather than that feeling of catch
up you know that feeling if you wake up
and you go I just want to go back to bed
then that's a really difficult place to
be in if you've got to perform that
evening because then an anxiety comes
into you're gonna be withdrawing on
reserves that are not replenishable I
don't go out after any shot and I would
love to you to come and see I'm doing
the music man come but I I never go out
and I make that's a blanket rule I don't
go out with anybody
hardly because the party I've just had
on stage is better than anything I can
imagine anywhere else the other thing is
that it's really important to me to get
quiet to allow what has happened the
energy of what has happened because
there is a lot of energy I mean I think
I'm the only actor I know who I can be
asleep within 45 minutes after getting
off stage there's something very calming
it's not it's like you've got had your
greatest workout you have a bar that
feeling after the bath after a great
workout in the evening where you just
can sit and be at peace with yourself
that I love so I limit the amount of
coffee I have just because you're
battling dehydration with stage work all
the time I always I have I know what my
routine is before I go on stage and I'm
RELIGIOUS about it and that's more about
quieting my mind I don't ever want my
monkey mind saying oh you didn't do your
warm up today or you only half did it or
this or that you haven't stretched you
haven't done that you didn't really eat
very well today you might be you know
the mind can't my mind can easily pick
up on that the perfectionist side of me
I always take a minute before I go
onstage literally before to pause and
just connect with the senses so even if
I'm not in the opening of a show I will
stand in the wings I first of all like
to just listen to that titter of
excitement of people come in to the
theater because I love to theater myself
and I remember that and a room
mine's me of how privileged I am and how
much I owe every single audience member
at every single show they're not coming
in to see my fourth show of the week
they're coming to see the show for the
first and probably only time in their
lives so and I who knows what they've
sacrificed to get there so I really take
that minute and then I fall still and
remind myself that this is all in
service of something I say a little I
say I'll put a mic the mean the month
which means I dedicate this show or
whatever it is to the service of the
absolute there is something beyond the
show some reason we're doing this same
for your shop you know there's got to be
a reason beyond just what the immediate
thing is that and that just connects me
to that I'm pretty quiet during the day
when I do a show and the other thing I
really try to do is read and listen to
other stuff I had a great acting teacher
Lyle Jones who said to me goes you can't
call yourself a real actor unless you
expose yourself to ballet and classical
music and David Adom wrote like you
should be so inquisitive and curious and
find inspiration from surprising places
can be a walk in the woods but that
stuff feed you so that in the act of
performing which is very much giving out
you have enough energy debt and stores I
suppose there'd be the main things I'm
so pleased we finally made time to get
on the podcast this is just fantastic
huh me too man I was telling before we
gonna I'm gonna side now I was a little
nervous I was actually so I went for a
bike ride this morning and it's not I
wasn't nervous like heart pounding like
I'm about to go on a talk show and I've
got to perform there we're not that kind
of nervous but I think because this is
the only thing I can think of only bit
of media really that I
we consume that I'm now participating in
and I thought the most of what why do I
consume it and the reason that I listen
in is that I have learned apart from
people in my inner circle I've learned
more from your show in the last two
years than anywhere else
I count less examples Seth Godin there's
two Pharrell Samaras you know I do he's
waking up and quite regularly so there's
so many things that I've learned and I
always feel like I'm going to get some
wisdom that has that wall helped me in
life all other people I love and and I
think the nervousness came from a bit of
a habitual thought Pat with me is like
oh well you know they're good like you
don't know how much man nothing like you
know you know you know you've done all
right but you're not the person that
people are gonna listen to on Tim
Ferriss you know I get tickets
you know those doubt those doubts that
clearly have fueled me in my life and I
I mentioned that I eat a compliment you
on what you've created but they just to
be completely open and honest that I
have those doubts you know that I'm I'm
not good enough which have driven me and
yeah sorry if I'm going off off please
here no I
you're not going off piece there's no
such thing in these conversations and I
really appreciate the kind words and
means a lot to me that you listen to the
show and I also want to say that for
those people who might wonder what you
are like in person that that there's
always a risk in meeting your heroes
meeting the people you might be inclined
to put on a pedestal and as far as I'm
concerned you are in person with your
friends with your family with your fans
everything that someone would hope you
to be so I want you to know that at
least for me you are one of the most
reassuring of
profile celebrities in that sense
because it is easy to kind of fall for a
facade and you've been very inspiring to
me in person and I'll just give a few
examples or I'll talk about a pattern
that I've observed which is that you are
polite to everyone I mean I've seen you
you shake hands with everyone you meet
you from from the whether it's the sort
of janitor up to a prime minister you're
you extend the same courtesy
to everyone and I think that's I think
that's a rarity no thank you for thank
you for being you and I'd like I'd like
to ask about in a sense how you were
shaped and I'd love to ask about your
your dad if if that's possible and I
have a specific example that jumps to
mind and this is from a piece some time
ago in Good Housekeeping so I want to
give credit where credit is due but the
the quote here and feel free to correct
it this is from you I remember at one
point being in a fellowship and everyone
used to wear the fish symbol that said
you were a Christian so I asked my
father dad why don't you wear that at
work and he said your religion should be
in your actions yeah he said a great
great example I could you speak to what
impact your your father or family had on
you in terms of of lessons learned yeah
I'm glad you mentioned a story that
actually came to mind a couple of days
ago my dad you know when people talk
about their oh my father always told me
this there weren't many times the dad
would come up with a sentence like but
there's a few I remember you cannot over
invest in education that's one he would
say to us and he says if you're ever in
doubt of what to do go and learn more
because what he would say your actions
that one it was I I actually now
remember it it was I was very we grew up
very religious my father was converted
by Billy Graham and my mother and father
I think went to the Billy Graham cruise
my father was not religious at all and
became a born-again Christian my mother
did not that was one of the things
actually I think they'll you know
brought the end of their marriage they
sort of went down different paths and my
book my dad was not a a Bible basher he
did he rarely talked about it and I
remember saying that because I was
really about 1314 I was really in school
a church groups fellowship groups and
and I got one of those stickers could
you put on the back of the car and I
said dad we should put that like we
meant to do that we meant to spread the
word and do this and when he said that
to me I was disappointed I thought it
was copping out but only later did I
realize that when he said people should
know you're a Christian through your
actions he's so much more powerful if
someone eventually comes up to you and
says you know there's something about
you man
I don't know what it is but I'd love to
know where I can get it you know then
there's an opening but someone people
have noticed how you act is far stronger
than what you say and we all know that I
often speak a little more about my dad
in interviews because my mom left when I
was 8 so I was brought up from the
moment on primarily by my dad and so I
got a lot of those lessons as I was
growing into a man with him being around
but my mom I always remember her saying
she says it to this day everyone needs
to feel appreciated it doesn't matter
what they do it doesn't matter who they
are that's a need in everybody and I
sort of have extrapolated that out to
mean people need to be seen I've learned
a lot of that from brené Brown they need
to be seen for who they are and
appreciated for what they give and I've
seen my mother in particularly my father
do that and that's something we were all
taught so it has become a natural thing
and it really pleases me I see that in
my kids too now that they've picked up
on that and it's a little really doesn't
take a lot but it it's that outward
facing understanding where people come
I'm walking in their shoes to a certain
degree and no one to be honest there's
no better example of that in my life
than my wife Deb she's but she's because
you could argue that I that's the way I
was brought up it's kind of like manners
you know that's the way I was taught to
be you know I couldn't go to someone
else's house into this day I always
offer to clean up even if I'm go to
someone's dinner party they always say
no I always if there's a bowl of chips
on the table
I will offer it I won't pick one up
until I've offered them to everyone
around me even if it's not my house all
that stuff that I've learned
but my wife acts purely from instinct
from heart so she she cannot walk past
someone homeless in the street and you
know I'll stop quite often but sometimes
I'll go I'm just too busy I can't deal
with this right now she will never do
that it's like an instinct in the
impulse that kind of that's where I
think manners are anyway you're brought
up and somehow goes to another level of
truly connecting that's what I've learnt
from her so there they've been three big
influences and Deb Deb is of course an
amazing amazing woman in her own right
and if she would like I can certainly
link to some of her works and the show
notes as well because I do think that
the sort of dynamic duo of the two of
you is a very important you know
combination you know with this I can't
tell you how many people invite us for
dinner and they'll be saying listen if
he's busy that's fine I'd love to ask
about journalism or communications this
is maybe gonna seem to remember what it
was about my dad
Oh fireless that's because I particular
on ethics if you get an invitation to go
who's I don't go across the road
teammates place cadena and then an hour
later you get an invitation from the
Queen of England
to go to the buckin palace you stick by
your first one it was just a stickler on
ethics you keep your word no even if it
does not benefit you you always keep
your word
that was big what my dad was always big
on ethics and yeah and the other
beautiful one I remember when my because
his relationship didn't work out and it
was a big source of pain for him that's
you know he's shared with me it was a
real feeling of failure for him around
his marriage you know when things had to
take off for me with x-men he very
rarely offered advice
at all about parenting nothing even when
I asked him for advice at one point at
one point I had an opportunity to be in
a TV show I got cast on TV show and the
same time I got a spotted a very revered
acting school in Australia the West
Australian cannot be performing arts and
over the weekend I had to choose to I go
on neighbours which Kylie Minogue I
piers smugger Robbie you know all these
people doubt so that was the breeding
ground or do I go and study for three as
I asked my dad on the Friday I said dad
I don't know what to do I need your help
and and I was 22 at the time and he said
I can't ask there for you and I was
really come on please
anyway by the Sunday it was clear to me
I wanted you know obviously he's lesson
about education it sunk in and so I went
now I need to go and study because I
want to feel that not only do I belong
on you know a TV series set but I can
also audition for the Royal Shakespeare
Company in in England and so and I
didn't feel I had that before I studied
so I went off and studied and when I
told Dad the decision he he'd I remember
he saw us ah thanking us
I said you know and he goes of course on
you I see couldn't you just save me this
grief that lasted eizan Talman he goes
man he says you're a man you have to
make those decisions on your own now as
a father I have a 20 year old I don't
know if I've got to hold my tongue
if I could see it so clearly go
I go left to be able to hold back that
was another great bit of advice I've
gone off and what were we talking about
before well I was gonna bring up
journalism and communications but I
might go we can go somewhere else I was
that that was one topic sort of on the
list but we we can go in any direction
that we like I'll tie it in in the sense
it's a it's a curiosity for me as to how
you came to be so well-spoken
there are many performers I've met many
people who are excellent on stage on
camera who nonetheless in person or an
interview otherwise are not as facile
with words as you are and I noticed in
in doing homework and I don't know if if
this is if this is a factor but that you
were initially well I should say and at
the University of Technology in Sydney
studying communications in hopes of
becoming a journalist
is that true true you know I'd love to
hear you speak to why that's the case
and and perhaps just try to paint a
picture of how you came to use words in
the way that you do um thank you man now
I haven't had that Khumbu before I'll
take it
you're welcome I've hundred four hundred
plus people and I can tell you my wife
says I can be a little too verbose
sometimes you're like all right got it
got the point wrap it up so I I if I
look back I was always in the debate
team love debate my brother is probably
the most successful barrister in
Australia certainly in his field of law
an incredible debater my other right
like so we used to get into it at home
and certainly with my oldest father was
a Rhodes Scholar you had to be on your
game or he would literally eviscerate
you in one line so I probably learned
pest there cutter reminds me of Jordan
saying I really learned how to play
basketball from trying to be my brother
growing up you know
and then I was in the debate teams and
all of that and we always had family
dinner every night Sunday lunch as a
family
there was always conversation so in a
way that was always encouraged and in my
family I'm certainly I don't stand out
as a speaker but if I think about it now
that was really something is always
prized and so I came out of high school
with pretty good scores and I was
accepted into a degree a dual degree in
economics and law interesting my father
was a my brother was a lawyer or going
into law at that time my father was an
accountant his whole life for Price
Waterhouse and I was good at maths and
and I really was interested in people
and good at speaking so Lauren economics
and I went off and I had a gap year help
me through the gap here I was like I
actually I think I don't think that's
for me but an inner allure I just knew I
was very much a people person and
interested in that and this
communications course was new at the
time and in Australia and I I went and
studied there without really knowing
anything about it to be honest um but I
knew media was a big part of it and
gradually as I went along my love
particularly for radio more than writing
boss and and so I did graduate with a
journalism major that degree but
honestly the biggest thing that happened
for me at college was that I did a play
in my last semester which I didn't mean
to do I was doing I had to fill one mine
or elective and my friend said you got
to join the theatre class because it's
the easiest thing possible you turnout
for four hours a week there's no exam
there's no play and you pass so I like
Trident done so he decided for the first
time in the courses history to do a play
and I begged to get out of it and by
ballot I got the lead role no there's no
auditions and only when I graduated as I
was graduating I realize I've just spent
90% of my time doing that play and
loving it and I said there's something
wrong here
like I'm am I'm doing investigative
journalism surely I should be really
more passionate about that maybe there's
something's off we weren't actually
toward the play to another university
that was half theatre and a half
communications and I remember viscerally
walking into the place where we were
staying we're staying at a student house
were eight people in this house
the smell of weed was suffocating his
overall Dean but what I remember was the
moment I walked in to that house and I
met those people I had this feeling all
over my body that I'd made a mistake
that I should have been here no I should
have been doing this course I knew then
and it was deeply frustrating to me to
be three weeks away from graduation
thinking oops I think I turned right Naz
made a turn left
and so yes officially I graduated as a
journalism major but I never studied it
I went straighten to go and study acting
after that so that was my sliding doors
moment I guess but that it has finally
enough I do get a lot of journalists and
I don't consider you a journalist you
describe yourself as a journalist him no
I think though it insults any any I
don't know I've got a lot more
understanding of the world around me
from your podcast and almost everything
I read so I appreciate that
oh by the way Ken Burns you thank you
for putting me on the Ken Burns I
amazing
during this whole quarantine I watched
all Civil War I watched the whole of
Vietnam and my son I about to get into
baseball that I mean how I could go 51
years without really seeing everything
Ken Burns has done is a crime but anyway
thanks for that yeah a special that uh
and that that podcast he did with him is
incredible so but anyway it was yeah
journalism has come in handy for me
because I talk to a lot of journalists
and I instinctively have an empathy for
them I think most people in my side of
the game fear not fear them don't like
them like
just trust them see them as a battle and
I don't care though I know the pressures
they're under how little they're getting
paid and that often they're being asked
told to ask questions of me that they
don't want to ask but they're told if
you don't come back to the newsroom
without a quote about whether he's gonna
have another child or blah blah blah
you know I'm don't come back so I can
see that when I'm listening to them I
just have an empathy and a real
appreciation for what they do because
when faced with the all right you've
graduated go be a journalist I was like
I don't think I can cut it I don't think
I can do it it's a really really hard
job so it has come in handy at the end
of drama school did you make a contract
with yourself about pursuing acting and
could you speak to that please
so I grant Dave your research is good so
I had worked out and I had my jobs I
graduated drums call 26 so gas station
attendant I dressed up in a koala suit
for the National Parks and Wildlife
Foundation I talk Walla Oh totally
and yes I've been punching the kidneys
by 14 year olds you know that whole
thing and yes I told him to [ __ ] off but
all of that you know restaurants but the
thing I learned from working in all
those jobs that if you start a business
it could be a pizzeria it can be a bar a
restaurant anything you have to give it
seven days a week for five years and
after five years you may be able to pull
back a little bit you may be able to be
in a position where you've built the
brand to a certain point you may have to
you may be able to hire a manager you
may be out of hire staff to make things
a little easier um but no one really
goes into owning their own business
thinking of this is gonna be the easy
life they do it because they there's
something they want to create they don't
want to be told what to do and they go
out and make it happen
and it dawned on me really only in the
last semester of drama school that
that's
I'm going out there there's no no one's
employing me in their company to be an
actor and then sending me out I have to
go and rehire every time I go for a job
and my brand is my name so I have to
build that up and so I thought okay what
about learned from all these jobs I've
got to give us seven days a week so I
vowed to never wait for the phone to
ring I was going to write letters I was
gonna start me and Simon Lyndon my fella
made I graduated with we're gonna start
a theatre company which he did by the
way I ended up getting a job straight
out of drama school got lucky but the
Terramax rock rock surfers which is you
know in Bondi in Australia still going
today after 25 years but my feeling was
you have to drive you have to work you
cannot be a victim you cannot wait for
the phone to ring you have to go out and
generate and get your brand out there
and get going so I figured five years
was the time because I was 26 so five
years only 31 we all hear stories of
people staying too long at the party I
mean if you go to LA there's two certain
people who stay a good 10 years too long
at the acting party you know and they're
like oh I met a guy my gym and he's
introduced me he's the guy who parks the
car around the corner of his place he
knows someone who's a friend of the
casting agent he's putting a win I think
I'm gonna get it you know that story
comes out and this feeling of it's gonna
happen next week and I figured 31 ok 31
if it's not happening be stoic by the
way thanks for Ryan holiday in the
stoicism all that stuff love be stoic be
hopeful but work your ass off but no one
has time to leave the party so after
five years at 31 I done x-men it was all
sort of happening for me it didn't
happen immediately in terms of what most
people think of a success but certainly
after their first 5 years I did actually
mentally sad myself alright another five
years and we'll see how it goes I don't
like the word career I'd particularly
began and I say directors I said I'd be
wary of the word career I said it's not
a right there you can I act 98% of our
unemployed it's a privilege when you get
a job and don't expect that always be
one around the corner work your ass off
as oh this is the last one and you have
to be at your best to get there because
that's kind of what it takes
so I all admit I don't redo the contract
anymore
just a quick thanks to our sponsors and
then we're right back to the show first
up magic spoon magic spoon is a brand
new cereal that is low carb high protein
and zero sugar it tastes just like your
favorite sugary cereal but it's actually
good for you my favorite flavor is cocoa
each serving has 11 grams of protein 3
grams of net carbs 0 grams of sugar and
only 110 calories try magic spoon today
by grabbing a variety pack at magic
spoon dot-com / Tim that's magic spoon
comm / Tim second and last expressvpn
expressvpn keeps my data secure and
encrypted all without slowing down my
internet speed it is so easy so fast you
don't even notice it's running so if
you're on public Wi-Fi anywhere and
don't want your data sniffed you don't
want creepers looking in on what you're
doing this is what I use go to
expressvpn comm slash Tim to get an
extra three months free on a one-year
package that's expressvpn comm / Tim
what were some of the best decisions
that you made in the first few years of
working hard padding the pavement as as
an aspiring slash working actor I will
definitely go into drama school that's
before that was a huge turning point I
had a big I just had also had this
attitude you got to say yes to
everything when you graduate just say
yes go for everything when my agent
called me and said they're looking for
someone to play guest on and being the
beast in the musical I was like well I'm
a theater icon I'm not a singer she said
you know I just think you should go for
it and me saying yes to that audition
and going getting singing lessons was a
huge turning point though I mean you
know now I've done a bunch of musicals
and I've learned a lot of it as years
but I did not think I could ever do that
so that was that was a big one in doing
beauty in the Beast
and in my contract I think I must be the
only actor in history in my contract it
said must get a singing lesson once a
week paid for by the company I was a
professional on paper professional
musical theatre actor and I had to go
and get singing lessons which I love man
cuz I was singing eight times a week in
a show getting a seemless in every week
that's really where I learned how to
sing so that year was amazing for me but
I had him this was more of a turning
point after I remember when I was doing
Beauty and the Beast I started that
getting well-known for that and I
remember seeing something like they had
a list of people what do they do for
Christmas kind of thing and they had
Hugh Jackman comma singer and it was up
at the theater someone put it up in the
theatre and I just remember going oh oh
I'm being labeled there's a singer I
said I'm an actor like this is gonna
this is a problem this is gonna affect
me and it did become a problem I
couldn't get an audition for film
because there was I don't know about the
rest of war but in Australia a kind of
snobbishness about musical theatre that
you weren't an actor you were a
performer stagehand you know jazz hands
and that's not acting so anyone in
musical theatre can act since I couldn't
get an audition driving me crazy so I
made a choice then to get out basically
I'm gonna get out of theater musical
theater and I'm just gonna concentrate
on acting until I've established that
then maybe I can go back to it and just
as I decided that my agent Raymond said
Trevis so Trevor Nunn is coming to do
Sunset Boulevard in Melbourne I said I I
said I really want to meet Sir Trevor
Nunn he was a huge hero of mine through
drama school the Royal Shakespeare
Company really I like huge I really
wanted to meet him that's who that's
really who I wanted to work for but it
was a musical and this was another 12
months and I thought now it's gonna be
back-to-back musicals I'm gonna be even
more entrenched down this path that you
know it's a one-way street
I actually yeah and I think back is a
pretty arrogant thing I bring the
casting director myself and I said I
need you to do me a favor and I had met
I knew her I said I really want to meet
Trevor and I want to audition for him
but I don't want to do the job
she said what what he meant I said I
really want to meet him but I've made
this decision I've got to go into acting
but can you just do me a favor I just
want to meet him and I want him to see
me act so I went in the audition was the
most incredible hour I've ever spent I
learned so much like one hour on our
audition he taught me so much about
acting he heard me sing and then he came
and worked with me for 40 minutes and I
remember about halfway through that
going okay if he gives me the part I'm
gonna do it it doesn't matter to me if
it's a musical or not I've got to work
with this guy I feeling oh my god I've
got so much to learn from him and that
was a massive turning point I got the
part I learned an incredible amount from
him he then went on to cast me in
Oklahoma in London and really working
with him gave me the confidence to be
able to take on the world stage I'm not
sure I would have had the confidence to
do that before him but I suppose the
lesson of that or the turning point of
that was when you have that gut feeling
go with it and I haven't always done
that by the way and you're gonna learn
actually not long after so after I did
Sunset Boulevard I doubled down on my
commitment to not doing musicals right
or after Oklahoma I'd now done three
musicals and I still couldn't get an
audition for a film and I got an offer
to do the Boy From Oz which I went on to
do here and on Broadway about 15 years
ago and when I heard the pitch for that
show I had that same feeling in my gut
oh my god this is gonna be amazing you
got to do it but my head was saying
you've done three musicals stop when are
you gonna start you gonna stop you made
a commitment so I turned it down and
when I went to see that show two years
later by the way I still hadn't got a
film audition pretty much when I went to
go and see that show
I was actually sick to my stomach
because it was everything I knew it was
gonna be when they pitched it to me and
there I was making some strategic plan
in my head and it was wrong and from
that moment on I have always followed my
gut on stuff even if it doesn't make
sense I have so many questions about
this I love where we're going and I was
gonna ask you about intuition but first
I have to ask just a brasstacks question
which is the casting director who did
this favor for you why do you think they
did that because that seems to me to not
be a small ask why do you use my why did
they feel compelled to do that what
persuaded them
um hmm it's a small industry in
Australia and I just come out and I've
got quite a lot of recognition I think
for that first musical and I think she
was thinking I'll give him the benefit
of the doubt on this one because I think
I'll see him again in something you know
what I mean
and I really pitched to her the reason I
got into acting was I'd seen those you
know tapes from the Royal Shakespeare
Company that with their Barton tapes and
I watched so much of our Trevor Nunn and
to me that was my dream was to one day
be the Royal Shakespeare Company and
working for Trevor Nunn like that was my
dream so I think I pitched him very
passionately I owned up to the arrogance
I said I know this is a really unfair
thing to do and I to this day don't know
if she told him that or if they knew
maybe that's why
Trevor as I was telling that story
there's that way Trevor spent an hour
with me he was like I'm gonna convince
this guy to do it I'll know - but anyway
yeah it's a really good question as to
why it was it was a kindness but I'm I
mean remember her doing it through
gritted teeth
I remember her going hmm all right right
guy okay this is a this isn't this is
not the easiest ask she's ever received
but nonetheless it happened and in a few
of the instances you've mentioned you
have and not all but you've you've honed
it it seems over time listen to this gut
feeling this intuition this I would say
sensitivity that that you seem to have
even when you've had huge sunk cost
right so you've invested years into
education pointing in one direction and
then at the eleventh hour you go hmm
okay well I turned right I should turn
left and you turn left and then you have
these examples that you've given how do
you relate to intuition or that gut
feeling now is there a certain way you
think about it or have become more tuned
to feeling it and I'm asking in part
because I've spent a lot of my life
trapped in my
the front of my brain hyper analyzing
things and it has often been a
disservice because it's overpowered
feelings intuition on deals partnerships
friends or foes that I should have
listened to right so I'd just be curious
to know how you have you know developed
a relationship with listen to that yeah
is I've never been asked this question I
think this is probably the most vexing
most important vital thing to work out
in your life certainly in my life and I
think about it a lot to answer the
question what I do now I I just I think
I need to take you back I've never
really said this before publicly this
particular thing I'm gonna say but as I
told you I was brought up in a very
religious household so a lot of the
messages I was getting and instructions
for life came through the examples of
Jesus and through all these characters
and the parables in the in the Bible and
I carry them very close to my heart I
can remember praying nightly for I don't
know how long to God Isis I remember
it's a saying I don't care God what it
is you want me to do if you want me to
click trash I'll click trash if you want
me to I do not care but please make it
clear to me what you want me to do
please make that clear I had much more
fear of being on the wrong path then I
had fear of failing at a path if that
makes sense that whatever that decision
was whatever that moment of clarity
becomes whatever gets you to that
feeling of Eric Liddell and Chariots of
Fire I see all these pleasure when I run
for me that was always and I carry it
today even though my feelings about
religion that different than what they
were when I was younger the essence is
the same that there is some calling the
Joseph Campbell would talk about follow
your bliss there is some calling that is
beyond the
conscious brains strategizing of how to
be happy and successful in meaningful in
life there's something elemental and
instinctual and honing that the people I
admire the most really hone that ability
and in big decisions their life and in
too small day-to-day decisions so now I
still like you battle with that because
I can be dominated by my mind my brain
pros and cons think this through and I
have been working with a lot life coach
Lauren Zander now for four years and
this is one of the biggest things we
focus on really understanding what it is
you're here for what it is you want to
do having those priorities very clearly
set out so that those turning points in
your life become clear and just to add
to that when you get married or when you
make a commitment a lifelong commitment
to someone and you have kids then the
first question Devin I will always ask
is is good or bad for a family so if
it's bad we won't do if it's good we
will you know so that's a very simple
thing but that's my number one priority
and I just remembered the thing about my
dad when I I don't think I said it when
I got famous and things were going
really well for me he turned to me
inside he said don't forget to always
check that everything's ok with dev at
every point and I was like oh ok that's
great advice
oh so anyway I got off pace but that the
decision-making I still ask that every
day you know I do it and I should have
mentioned this up front in terms of that
first question you asked me in terms of
performing and the things you do you
know daily I do a daily design every day
I create as if in the past tense of what
the day had been dreams can be crazy can
be wild and then at the end of the day I
I score it had a 10 I keep myself
accountable to what I was trying to
manifest
or make happen and one thing I
consistently and that is that I listen
to the messages that they come in crazy
ways they come in strange but clear
concise ways
okay so I've just come full circle let
me give you an example I'm gonna go back
again I in terms of knowing to get into
acting right following those examples I
went and studied sorry audition for an
acting school and I got in I got in on
the reserve list so I didn't get on the
first time around this was a one-year
course I did before my three-year one I
just snuck in and I was so excited after
graduating as a journalist I can't
really go to acting school for one year
and then I got a letter in the mail
a week later saying congratulations
you're in please make sure you come with
the three-and-a-half thousand dollars
tuition fee and it had never dawned on
me that I was gonna cost anything
because when I was young in Australia
secondary education was free I call
university was free so I was like oh and
I thought I've gotta go and ask my dad
and I've just graduated from college and
I thought I can't do that I literally
ripped up the letter screwed it up put
it in the bin and I'm not joking this is
to me one of those signs crazy signs
that are just like a wall up in the face
I got a check the next day from my
grandmother's will she died three months
before for three and a half thousand
dollars the exact dollar amount and out
yeah I mean that that's an obvious
example that's when the universe is
going alright you're an idiot I've given
you a lot of signs you went off and did
that play you walked into that house you
got that sign you knew this is where
you're meant to be this is it and maybe
it's time to move on and you're about to
throw it up because the three-and-a-half
thousand dollars and that party me to go
down you're gonna kind of falter the
first hurdle and then the wallop cans my
face and so I've had really clear
moments of that but I asked every single
day Tim not ask I manifest every single
day that I will hear those messages and
they're not just about me
my kids there about my wife there about
my friends there about purpose there
about meaning there about life I'm in
coffee there's all of that stuff dad the
direction I'm meant to go will become
clear to me a hundred percent clear in
my gut
remember I said by being ferbos to kana
and away oh no I wouldn't save verbose
this is definitely suitable for long
form okay the question of intuition so
one of the fine tuning questions I have
which is based on something you said
earlier which is even if it sometimes
doesn't make sense what I've noticed in
my own experience is that often times in
retrospect the most important times to
listen to intuition which you could
think of any number of ways right you
could think of it as a few million years
of pre verbal evolution giving you a
signal you could think of it in in a
multitude of ways but oftentimes the
most important examples of me listening
to intuition have been when it is
seemingly made no sense right where it
hasn't been obvious are there any
examples that come to mind for you where
you're like it just didn't seem to make
sense I couldn't connect the dots at the
time but I just felt I knew I had to do
X are there any examples like that that
come to mind and if not that's okay as
well um you know when I perform on stage
there I ad lib quite a lot I go off the
script I go to things have pulled people
out of the audience I do stuff like that
I learned that from doing the Boy From
Oz where the character did that ten
minutes a night and this is not a big
life-changing moment but first thing
that came to mind was just last year I
was on stage and I never plan people
always think I've either planted someone
in the audience because of what comes
out there either be funny or something
will happen or I've at least spent the
first half of the show scouting the
audience and scanning and to see who I'm
gonna pick but I don't I use that as an
example of just trusting that in front
of 20,000 people the Madison Square
Garden I'm just gonna go with my gut on
hood appear
and that's something and there's a
reason for that and I promise you 9
times out of 10 something happens that
is just crazy and maybe it's because of
that intention to be open and just to
meet the situation as it arises but I
remember being in Sydney and in the
middle of the show I'd spotted this kid
you know and I was going on seeing as
how I stopped the song something in my
head said you gotta grab that kid so I
said I went on and the kid was dressed
in the greatest showman outfit that's
probably what attracted my attention
which is not uncommon to be honest but I
went and grabbed him and he came up on
stage and he started getting teary um
and I was worried that actually I got it
like an 11 year old kid up on stage and
it been overwhelming for him and so I
just sort of brought it down and then he
shared his story that he had just this
was his first outing after covering from
brain surgery and that the greatest
showmen was the thing he listened to
every single day the being here come
long story short I looked out myself
included he his father had also died his
father was a famous guitarist I didn't
know any of this in Australia in a
famous band he had died two years before
so the day he got his diagnosis and by
the way he not all this came out on
stage I found a lot of this out Afton's
but something in this kid made the
entire audience melt and cry
they kid ended up staying on stage with
us for the entire evening his dream was
to one day perform he grabbed his guitar
he I got his guitar oh he's saying in
front of 20,000 people he got a standing
ovation tears are streaming down my face
everyone you know he then went backstage
he joined us for the rest of our time as
sinigang backstage with his mum and
this was you know when you're doing a
show with a hundred people in an arena
and your brain goes go over that kid my
head was screaming don't listen to that
your harpy throat number you're two
hours into the show people have already
been here for blah blah but like this is
that you know and going with that that
moment was one of the most
transformative in the entire thing and I
have no idea why I came to me and I have
no idea why I stopped but I'm really
grateful I did it seems to me from the
outside looking in at least that you've
cultivated the ability to surrender in
specific circumstances like that if that
makes any sense at all you know that
seems to be a huge strength I want to
come back to something you said and work
on that by the way I really have cuz I
can be a bit of a controlled you worked
on it um with Lauren's Anna my coach she
always joking she goes oh I look perfect
Tommy she's like she's good you got this
alter ego perfect Tommy in there she
gets him from buckaroo banzai don't know
if you ever saw that eighties movie yeah
yeah so and perfect Tommy right she goes
are you're curving Tommy so you know
sometimes even when you gave me that
compliment the beginning when you say
you know you seem to be you know you're
always kind to everyone I'm like man is
that the real me or is that just perfect
Tommy you know so but she's really made
me work on that and to trust myself do
the work that you need to do don't do an
ounce more than you need to do and I was
more prone to be an over worker an over
warrior and miss some of the fun of my
life because of it and I really worked
hard on doing that on film of letting go
on stage of not letting my own
expectations getting away and if we if
we come back to the design of the day if
I'm remembering the phrasing you used is
that a paragraph that you write down in
a journal or type out in the morning
which if I'm if I'm getting this is
today I did xed a I felt this it's past
tense for the day to come it's happened
so it's yes it's a past tense it's
already happened there's no
really hope I think that I'm I hope I'm
gonna try and I will like today my my
son and I had the best hour together
laughing and talking and we connected on
some of the most elemental things in
ways we've never connected that kind of
thing
it would you will have and I do that
every morning on a text which I send to
her because she says you know we all
need to be accountable to someone um and
I'm looking at them now our relationship
goes to new levels of honesty and
intimacy so that's you know just just
that kind of thing that the dev and I
can who it's the best really the most
successful part of my life there's my
family life bud wanna go for more
there's new levels there's other things
there must be things that I'm keeping
you hidden or am ashamed over that I
that I should share you know so I write
that every day and then either that
night or if I'm too tired in the morning
I read it again and go off Wow [ __ ] that
was a four out of ten like that they did
not turn it out at all like that and
then it's got to do with belief really I
and I'm new to this man I like my wife's
always been into manifestation and I was
like I don't know if that's the way to
live life like you know isn't more to be
open like in presence and dealing and
that stoic way to deal with what's
coming can we really manifest her but
I'll give you a really great example so
of that manifesting the greatest showmen
and I have not told this story I was on
the fence about it for a long time
the studio were on the fence I wasn't
sure if they were gonna make it we I
wasn't I just wasn't sure of her script
was in the right place and I had lots of
reasons for that and so Lauren my life
coach who I found through dr. Mark Hyman
and has changed my life she all text me
saying I need to slap it and then I'm
like okay so I ring your Amish goes
alright
for example sometimes she'll ring up and
say you know thank you something I think
in general you're a good listener but
sometimes I think you're better looking
like a good listener and then you
we are a good listener I was like all
right challenge accepted slap taken but
in this case she said to me I think
you're preparing to choke I think you
are laying the safety net for the
greatest showman to be to not work and
you're thinking of all the reasons
outside of yourself why it won't work
and you have 24 hours to either decide
to get on or get off but if you're on
you need to be a hundred percent in and
I was like she's right
I wasn't preparing for Chuck what was
that it's like maybe preparing for Chuck
but I clearly it's easier to do that in
life no you know I'm gonna give it a go
I'll give him my pass you know look I'm
not sure musical is really hard original
musical is impossible you know I you
know with yes the studio one spend this
amount of money on this writer we wanted
we got this writer but you know we're
gonna give it our best like you're right
there in your language pretty much gonna
fail and you're preparing yourself for
the failure and you don't want to fall
too far so you've got the safety net so
that when it fails you go yeah well you
know it's just you know it's been a bit
more money on the writer or a
ba-ba-ba-ba-ba XYZ so I hung up the
phone
swap taken a little stunned and I just
sat down for about an hour and I
imagined what that movie was gonna be in
the tent and I imagined the effect it
would have and why we were doing it and
then I wrote all that down and then I
wrote that down every day to the day we
finished principal photography and then
I had to recommit again when were in the
editing process and I just let me be
clear our director by the way michael
gracey I I have such high regard for him
because from the moment we started in
eight years he was working on that film
everything that's happened with that
film he used to say this is what's gonna
happen this is gonna be a movie that's
gonna be around forever this is gonna be
one of the legacies of your career Hugh
ba ba ba he would say all these things
and I used to say to him I said Mike
this is your first film tone it down a
little bit
do it like why don't you just say we
make a great film do we have does it
have to be one of the most successful
films so he would literally say this is
the most successful musical of all time
and he would never deviate from that
ever so I'm not saying I was the only
person manifesting bad I do think that
was a big turning point and when Lauren
slapped me around that changed my
intention to that project completely and
I don't think that insures you against
failure add that quote of don't insure
yourself for failure you know what I
mean don't does don't have that safety
net out all the time I really learned
that from Lauren and that's probably one
of the best career examples I can give
of that daily design
what what strikes me about that is
number one the consistency the daily
practice the second is the
accountability like you said you know
text Lauren and which is something that
I now want to do even with a friend
I mean people listening could for
instance just find an accountability
partner where you text each other in the
morning and then at 5 p.m. or 6 p.m.
each evening you check in and you have
to score off against that accountability
partner it just seems like such a
wonderful practice and I'd like to like
to talk about practices and I just have
a few more questions for you and I'll
pull from a quote first you can you can
tell me if this is accurate or not this
is from an interview in Oprah Magazine
but it relates to meditation and I'm
going to use this as a segue but I love
the the analogy that you use which is
everyone takes a shower every day and we
don't complain about it we do it out of
discipline there will always be an
excuse not to meditate in the Hindu
tradition there's something called a
hung Cara if I'm saying that correctly
or the ego the egos are on Cara there we
go the ego says you don't need to
meditate you don't need to meditate man
you're really busy what about the kids
but do I say I can't shower today
because I have to make time for the kids
no and one of the I'm sure many elements
that seems to be a discipline for you is
your your physical practice exercise
you've transformed yourself multiple
times
certainly and I've seen you work out
it's it's enough to make me want to
retire my sneakers it's just outrageous
the intensity involved and I'd be
curious to know if there are any
particular exercises or types of
exercise that you have found to be
particularly good bang for the buck so
if you were if you had to just take the
desert Ellyn test and you could only
take a handful of exercises or x y&z
with you does anything come to mind
rolling machine definitely aroma there's
a reason the row is usually empty at the
gym because it's difficult and a lot of
people want to say it and feel they've
worked out and they want to get a sweat
but they don't necessarily and and I
learn a lot of this from your book you
know and I worked at a gym by the way
before our body I worked at a gym for
three years so I saw a lot of people
coming in five days a week and not
really changing anything about them and
the rowing machine I think if you add in
some chest works and push ups that's in
everything you need to keep fit healthy
strong and I've learned a lot of that I
work with Beth Lewis the trainer who if
you can look her up she does a lot of
free classes right now I think during
covered now I found her through Peter do
you know Beth have you met Beth I know
of death well she was a power lifter and
a dancer so she it really is great for
me because I mean in the past even with
someone like Wolverine I have to prepare
to look physically away but I can't get
injured so I can't prepare as a
bodybuilder I have to be able to prepare
there's a really jacked ripped athlete
slash dancer because fighting is dance
it is more relaxation in a fight scene
then there is strength which is probably
the case for if you think about all the
great athletes you see there's
relaxation and and and that movement has
moved in sports that's why you see every
sprinter poking their tongue out now and
dancing around with joy before they run
the hundred meters you know that sense
of having the right level of relaxation
I think they call it the 85% rule if you
tell a most sort of a type athletes to
run at their 85% capacity they will run
faster than if you tell them to run 100
because it's more about relaxation and
form and optimizing the muscles in the
right way so Beth has really taught me
that
but the rowing machine man you can't go
wrong you know and if you and
forget time just do the seven minute
thing and I had to do this for a film a
movie Australia Bears wanted me to be
big and so I was big in them about a
month before he said ah doing a lot of
research about these Jack aru's or
Cowboys he goes there lean they're all
lean lean lean and I'm like - you asked
me to get big up and getting big because
I need you lean so I went in my trainer
and he goes who was a rower and he said
you want to get a lean rope so a part as
well as the ice baths that I learned
from your book which I used all through
the Wolverines particularly the later
Wolverines when you see me in better
shape
that's a great way to lose fat but
7-minute row four times a week and the
goal is 2,000 meters and and when you
try it at some point you're gonna hate
me for it but still that's the quickest
best way okay that's that's excellent
advice yeah that the rower hits your
entire almost your entire posterior
chain and then you do some push-ups and
you're you're in good shape yeah it's
such a good building exercise for a
deadlifts and all these core movements
compound movements getting your scapula
everything sort of in the right place
and your breathing and relaxing your
neck you know at the same time is doing
it you know I would say the rower and I
love the the 85% run at 85 percent
effort example that you gave I find so
much truth in that statement I haven't
ever thought of it but you could apply
that to sitting down and writing you
could apply it to almost anything we're
being you're tense is not your friend
stuff going to help you not none and
that's my like everyone's got different
things if I was coaching me my cell like
if I was the coach and Hugh Jackman was
on my team
I wouldn't put more pressure on him push
him more I will yell at him scream that
I've got that motivation if anything I
have had to work from building up
insecurity so I'm not good enough I need
to work extra hard if I do everything
perfectly and I work my ass off then
I'll be okay
kind of thing which in the end does
certainly limit your ability to enjoy
life or enjoy the row or the show or
anything like that
but it doesn't get the best out of you
it really does it so I mentally quite
often during the day just before I do an
activity imagine that it's done that
feeling I have when it's done and gone
well and I go into it with that I love
that that a big - Frankel quote live
life as though it's the second time
around but you've got it wrong the first
time
here's a good one and that's that's what
works for me or even if you practice
simple thing to sit down and as you're
breathing in
imagine that you're breathing out
because a lot of us me included and I
and I got this from my singing teacher I
breathe in with her or I gonna sing this
big note
alright let's hope it goes well you know
and all the sudden I'm tense and my
breathing's gone up my larious goes up
and I'm gonna have to work my ass off
together no doubt right whereas the
great singers the ones that make you
melt when you listen to them sing when
they're breathing in preparing it's like
they're breathing out they're relaxed as
they breathe in and then be prepared so
there's some of the little things I use
and I I suspect you're a little similar
to me Tim right the idea [ __ ] you you
work better with the ID parkcentral I
definitely do I mean if I think about
the times when I've performed best it's
never when I'm whipping myself extra
fast and extra hard with a cat a ninth
writes because I don't need that no I I
don't like go into an opening night I do
opening night you feel that I like this
is happy night it's gonna be the best
and I just want to go hey chill out
everyone I prefer to go to a Wednesday
matinee six weeks into the run that's
when you're gonna see the best show so
the trick is how can you get there and
bother I dunno the 85% rule
do you know where that came from they
did up it came from a guy studying Carl
Lewis the sprinter sure he couldn't
understand why a guy who was routinely
coming last or second last after 40
meters which traditionally in sprinting
was meant to be where you won you won in
the first 40 from the start how someone
like that would always win by 10 yards
at the end and some people said well
he's just a slow starter but he's got a
long stride that it uh and then someone
this guy was studying it for a year the
Sprint coach and someone gave him
finally one of those head-on shots you
know they invented the Olympics that
head-on shot where you watch them come
down right and he watched it over and
over again and he said what he realized
Carl Lewis did at the 50 meter mark 60
meter mark was that he did nothing his
breathing was exactly the same his form
is exactly the same as had been between
meters 25 and 50
whereas everyone else starts to push to
the end trying on a total of extra
harder he said their face would scrunch
up their jaw would tighten their fists
would start to clench
whereas Carl Lewis stayed exactly the
same and then it would just breeze past
him so that's where he invented the 85%
rule I love it I love it I need more of
that in my life to be honest I think
that's something that I need to
cultivate and I just just if just a few
short questions left - I really
appreciate all the time and this one is
something I think is near and dear to
your heart and it's it's puzzles and
games see you yeah you some people know
this but not everybody realizes that
you're a connoisseur of puzzles and
games and I'm wondering first for
someone who has been perhaps a little
too serious taken themselves in their
work a little too seriously and they
need or want to explore puzzles or games
are there any that you might any
approaches or specific games or puzzles
you might recommend people start with
start with a thousand-piece write
anything once and that's probably gonna
be like a thousand pages good you know
and that'll take you a few weeks
probably but it's just enough of a
challenge um don't don't pick up the
black-and-white photo right on the front
cover to start with have some color make
it a little easier I love the company
Wentworth there's a few other puzzle
companies well when worth when you put
it's got like this some technology when
you put the piece in it's like squeezing
your pimple it does it i yes like you
know like there's some puzzles that I've
made a bit cheaply and you're like I
think that fits not sure this has got
something about it click technology or
something
so yeah clearly I'm into it that's
amazing see that after a show you say
what I like doing after show like if I
can't have my way I'd eat something and
I just been an hour doing a puzzle um I
actually have to set my alarm to make
myself go to bed because I can stay up
till 4:00 in the morning doing puzzles
and for someone with restless leg
syndrome
by the way it doesn't come up at all
when I'm doing puzzle let's start with
it Wentworth 1000 piece
two things you have any recommendations
on subject matter for the for the image
and then number two what do you get from
assembling puzzles what is it makes it
so addictive to you and so mesmerized it
um I like to do puzzles of places um
that I've been or live it like so or now
you can send in a photograph and I did
this one a Christmas so I did this for
Deb for Valentine's Day
I sent her a photo of the two of us
there's a shot she loves and we're on a
vacation to a place we always go to so
as I'm going through it it's reminding
me of where a bin of that feeling in
that moment and because you look at a
scene or the ones of New York you're
looking at this scene for about a month
and you're focusing in my new details of
this building that building or that tree
this tree when you go back to that place
you go out into their world your
appreciation of the world is so much
greater I I guess I'm not an artist but
at how artists must feel when they're
trying to solve color that when they
watch a sunset they're appreciating in a
way far more they lose too soon they
spend all that time immersed in
different colors and combinations and
composition um why is it so addictive I
don't know like the reason I got into it
I got into her at a point but father had
just had an operation or something I
thought I gotta find something for the
two of us to do together and he had no
interest like we were at 30 minutes in
and he was like yeah I'm out I had not
done a puzzle since I was like 8 years
of age and now I'm addicted to him so
it's tough for me I think it's probably
another form of meditation in a way it
stops my mind going there is a weird
sense of accomplishment even in every
piece got their pace it's its detail its
your zoning in on this image for a month
and looking at it and looking at the
detail
um it's just deeply satisfying to my
mind in my being I just I just feel
really relaxed when I do it I feel
guilty when I do it because it's a very
solitary thing and I try and get the
kids involved you know really to upset
the guilt but they're not into it really
so you know yeah
it sounds like to me I need to take a
picture of a beautiful outdoor space
have it made into a puzzle read the
overstory and work on yes for ya
that sounds like it would where do you
sit and have coffee do you sit out in
the backyard there where are you I sit I
sit outside I'm very fortunate to have a
lot of trees nearby take a photo of that
come on that's great it you send it off
to I think it's oh I'll send it you I
can't remember the name it off by heart
I put it on my website once my jigsaw
puzzle or something I'll put it anyway
that's what you said it to me too yeah
and and then when you go out for that
coffee it will always be different dear
you'll notice things that you've never
noticed before and that is I think
that's a big part of the art of living
it seems to me and is becoming sensitive
to noticing the little things because
hmm the little things like it couldn't
agree more
I couldn't agree more in isolation I
love to use that phrase art it is a not
that's I mean I used to think it was an
Australian thing like I think it was an
Australian thing like come on all the
Americans always have you know
therapists psychiatrists and come on you
know silly but it's a little arrogant to
think you've got it all sorted out why
wouldn't you want to help like Roger
Federer is the greatest tennis player of
all time and he is half full time coach
right right so why Pavarotti I ever seen
Pavarotti had a singing teacher to the
end of his life
why wouldn't we invest that in the art
of living and so certainly with me with
Oren Zander that's changed my life in
the last four years big time Hugh I so
enjoy our conversations and this has
been so much fun and I am really applaud
you for dedicating yourself to the art
of living and continual improvement and
also sharing your gifts with the world
that I think that you mean you really
are and I know I hope this doesn't come
off as trite sounding but you really are
what a die-hard fan would hope you to be
and I don't mean that in a superficial
way but the the kindness that they see
there the compassion that they see that
is not an illusion and I feel that's
important to underscore because I do
think it's rare I do think it's rare and
I recognized that that's not just how
you popped out of the womb that's
required deliberate thought and practice
and awareness so I really appreciate
that I appreciate you and thank you so
much for taking the time to to spend
yeah spend some time today honestly is
my pleasure really and keep up the great
work
and good luck with the puzzle man I'm
telling you I know I think I know enough
about you your girlfriend is gonna rue
the day I ever met
make sure I have a backup puzzle for
Valentine's Day and well risk and to
everybody listening you can find show
notes on everything we discussed and
there will be lots lots of goodies at
tube top vlog for slash podcasts and
until next time thanks for tuning in
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every Friday event provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek calm all
the spell out and just drop in your
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by magic
spoon magic spoon is a brand new cereal
that I eat just about every day that is
low carb high protein and zero sugar I
just ate a huge bowl of their cocoa
flavor about an hour ago
after a short workout magic spoon cereal
has received a lot of attention since
launching last year Time magazine
included in their list of best
inventions of 2019 and Forbes called it
the future of cereal it tastes just like
your favorite sugary cereal from
childhood remember that but it's
actually good for you each serving has
11 grams of protein 3 grams of net carbs
0 grams of sugar and only 110
calories it's also gluten-free grain
free cuter friendly soy free and GMO
free all the things it's delicious
and I don't say that lightly because
most of this healthy version of X stuff
is not delicious but these guys really
nail it magic spoon has nailed it it
comes in your favorite traditional
cereal flavors like cocoa frosted and
blueberry you can try them all by
grabbing a variety pack at magic spoon
comm / Tim or you can just grab box or a
bunch of boxes in the order some more
today of the cocoa which is my personal
favorite but there's a new contender for
favorite flavor because they just
launched two limited-edition flavors
honey nut and peanut butter which are
delicious I am a sucker for peanut
butter and it is so thick cocoa and
peanut butter are my two new favorite
flavors and fun fact my friends are also
obsessed with magic spoon one of the
podcasts was popular guest dr. peter tia
routinely crushes six to seven servings
at a time that's a lot with no glycemic
response he's lived with this with a
blue collar he likes it so much he
invested other friends two very fine
gentlemen and also past podcast guests
Kevin Rose Ryan holiday also invested so
check it out see what the buzz is about
go to magic spoon dot-com / Tim and grab
a variety pack of cocoa my favorite or
anything else but see what strikes your
fancy why not try a variety pack and be
sure to use code Tim at checkout my
listeners that's you get free shipping
and a 100% happiness guarantee so if
you're not a fan if you don't love it
they'll give you a full refund no
questions asked again check it out
magic spoon comm board / Tim that's
magic spoon comm /y Tim take a look
this episode is brought to you by
Express VPN I've been using Express VPN
since last summer and I started using it
as a full retail paying customer I
always test things before considering
sponsors and I find it to be a super
reliable way to make sure that my data
are secure and encrypted you like House
of data are like a pompous ass but I
like to ensure that my data are secure
and encrypted but to do so without
slowing down my internet speed if you
ever use public Wi-Fi at say hotel or
coffee shop where I often work and as
many of my listeners do you're often
sending data over an open network
meaning no encryption whatsoever one way
to ensure that all of your data are
encrypted and not to be easily read by
hackers or script kiddies or whoever is
by using Express VPN and the onboarding
process for expressvpn meaning the
signup flow the use of the product is
one of the best I have ever seen in my
life all you need to do is download the
Express VPN app on your computer or
smartphone and then use the internet
just as you normally would you click one
button in the expressvpn app to secure
100% of your network data it's kind of
ridiculously simple and as many of you
know I only recommend brands that I have
researched and vetted thoroughly for me
of the many VPN solutions out there
expressvpn is one of the best on the
market and I use it personally here are
a few reasons why first privacy
expressvpn does not log your data lots
of cheap or free VPNs make money by
selling your data believe it or not to
add companies and so on expressvpn
developed technology called trusted
server to prevent their servers from
login your information second speed many
VPN slow your connection down or make
your device seems sluggish just to a
crawl I've been using expressvpn for a
while now as I mentioned and my internet
speeds are blazingly fast I don't even
notice it honestly I forget that it's
even on so that includes when I connect
to servers thousands of miles away or
during travel I can still stream HD
new videos with zero lag the last thing
that really sets expressvpn apart is how
easy it is to use as I mentioned earlier
unlike other VPNs you don't have to
input a program anything you just start
up the app click one button and that's
it
super super simple and by the way it's
not just me saying all this about but
expressvpn you've got TechRadar reverb
CNET and many other publications rating
Express bpm as the number one VPN in
severe so consider protecting yourself
with the VPN that I use and trust use my
link expressvpn comm slash Tim today and
get an extra three months free on a
one-year package that's expressvpn
dot-com slash Tim visit expressvpn com
slash Tim
[Applause]
you
you
you